[Music]
they don't want to talk about an
approach to adding notifications
features to - custom analytical
applications so a little bit about me I
work at a company called intermix we do
a performance monitor for data platforms
and prior to that I was working at a
company called criticism intelligence
which was performance quality for mobile
applications and then earlier in my
career I co-founded one of the first
clock gating companies a little bunch of
patents in that area so this is really
geared towards individuals who might be
involved in projects where you're
building like a custom advanced
analytics application for your company
to deliver it to partners or customers
or to make the product veterans or for
internal use so think d3 charts or other
sort of charting application is that you
put yourself and so at some point what
will happen is that your customers will
love it and don't want the ability to
send emails or SMS to themselves when
certain charts behave in certain ways
and so this happened to us we hadn't
built our product as a monitor tools
we've got preach arts and things like
this that we show our users and you know
this is this is this is like a bird's
eye view of your cluster and then it
showed you through information about
stuff happening in an environment and
they loved it so much that you know but
they don't you know really want to be
logging in every single day and looking
at your data they just really want to be
able to get enough salient information
quickly this is good news it means that
the data that your provider them is
useful and so when one of these requests
to add notifications come in you have
two options you can you can build a
notification system yourself you know
and this is you know an ability to set
thresholds for certain metrics and rules
space way and then point and you know
send emails at notifications to various
channels which turns out is very very
hard to do or because most of your users
are already using a tool like pod watch
with beta dog just you know for sure
measure to those tools and set turns out
is the approach that we decided to take
and so a few considerations when
thinking about how to do this so that
our teams are considered work on the
inside you need to deal with all the
abilities right you need to think
through what additional complexity am i
adding to my application to my structure
to do this you know how easy is it to
manage this how will its scale and then
how durable is it you know fault
tolerance is obviously very important
when you're talking about analytics
when thinking through what to build from
you know the product perspective what
you know what kind of tools we want to
support the feature
I mean if most your customers use
because you're juice I watched something
used a the dog others use wavefront you
will get request to pushed up into those
tools as well so you should think
through minute that's how do you do that
what metrics will you said and then you
know how will these things change over
time from a cost perspective you really
want to focus on a solution that does
not require you to make a big capital
upfront expense
what you really want is to be able to
only pay a variable cost as you use your
sign up or as you sort of certainly
don't like add additional metrics to the
tool so what we ended up doing is
sending up an approach where the metric
data that's both on our platform where
we went in entirely service approach so
our our platform
stores data in elastic search and
redshift in this diagram
Theo represents you know the doctor farm
that runs a lot of our GTL
and so what we decided to do is add a
cue and then have
worker that will pop messages off that
IQ and push it into the the
identification system of choice and you
decided to use Kinesis and lambda and so
the way that the system works is we have
workers that will generate veterans it
will push them on Kinesis stream and
then we have two two lambda functions 1
1 is the async it is an async lambda a
lambda function that will pop messages
off with McNeese is queue and then it'll
trigger another layer of the function
that will actually push the measures
into cloud much in this case so I'll
talk a little bit of a lot like how you
know sort of how this approach works and
you know what were some of the
trade-offs that we made so this is a
great you know the DISA propel you ate
up some of the other options that I'll
show later really really gives you an
ability to not have to worry about
scalability because Amazon deals with
that you you know it's a low latency
solution the nice thing is that it's
very durable
there's a dead-letter Kingdom and in
lambda so any message that fails to be
delivered either because the cloud watch
API is down at the API of the
notification system is down the message
with the body is stored in a queue for
reprocessing um perhaps the best feature
of this architecture for us was that we
can multiplex this data and support
multiple ordered adhesion services
without having to make big changes to
the architecture so if we wanted to be
imported a system in addition to cloud
watch like data dog all we would have to
do is either extend the lambda functions
to push the message body into both
services at the same time or just build
another lambda function
tailor-made for that one services API
and so we wouldn't have to change how
the producers created the metrics and
push them onto the queue the Collinses
and it said it was for us we were you
know we're not using land up or benissa
at the time and so it's a wholly
separate sort of like kind of
infrastructure that we had to figure out
how to monitor our setup not gonna bore
you with the configuration on the left
but essentially the thing is lambda
functions the only one for five minutes
at a time you can get around that by
Fanning lambda out but anything that you
do you need to make sure that the
operation will take less than five
minutes in general some of the cosmetics
were interesting it's not free but it is
pay-as-you-go so the metrics that we
were pushing who were kind of one minute
granularity which turns out when you
look at the message body for us and you
might remember you being used by the man
the server turned out to be about point
73 or 70 cents per month which doesn't
sound like a lot but it does that you
know still path if you if you think
about all the metrics that you might
push across all the combinations of how
those metrics may be aggregated this
number could get into the hundreds of
dollars per month so it's something to
manage but you know at least when you
start you're starting at zero one of the
things that was interesting is that
lambda has at least one semantics we do
not we assume that it was exactly once
an address which we learn the hard way
after debugging for a few hours
apparently of the Google service Google
functions has exactly one semantics so
if this is important for your
application you can sort of play around
that other service what this means is
that the same message can be delivered
more than once with the same body so you
just have to you know have your
application deal with that for us it
didn't matter for this application
because it would just end up being two
sample counts within college for this
which did not change the annotation of
the metrics if applied watch you cannot
delete data there's no API to delete
metrics and so if you want to get rid of
a custom metric just stop pushing to it
and then it will be automatically
pruning go away average agrees one of
the other other kind of other nice
things is that Amazon deals with
aggregation for you so you don't have to
really worry about aggregating in as he
gets older the final one was for our
products in order to connect to our
customers clash environments we had to
set up a registration flow where my they
would authorize one of their roles a
trust relationship with our certain
Amazon account and it turns out that
with cloud wash you cannot get very
granular with kind of the permissions
you can assign you cannot say for
example I only want to read metrics from
this service you have to [ __ ] require
that you do star that you get kind of
all access or nothing that was a problem
for us because we you know we really
wanted to be able to read back the data
that we pushed to do data validation but
we weren't able to do that and so we
don't you did an audition at all so we
have to find a different way to do that
but that's something that that was
surprising to us it's not very easy to
get it's impossible to do that with
Amazon um you know they've got even a
few other approaches I'll share a little
bit of those here we had on the left
hand side you know we did a cube plus a
worker you sort of like that using our
own cue instead of using Kinesis the
pros of that would have been that we've
been sort of simpler to code because we
already have a docker farm then we could
have leverage for this but they only
have to manage the cute one more queue
and deal with the scalability of that um
we were also evaluated not using a queue
at all but that that was something that
was clearly not a good idea because of
the fact
we would be very very dependent on the
performance of the notification system
and you'd have no way of recovering of
the failures which was not acceptable so
in in practice the way that this looks
is in our application we have you know
these charts and we have a function
where in this example start to see but
when you click on the chart you can now
send any of the analytics for this chart
into cloud watch in this case we're
screaming row count information size
information for tables aggregated by
schema into cloud watch and then that
sort of shows up as a custom namespace
of cloudy box which is kind of that so
you can have as many of these as you
want and they sort of you know in the
message bodies whatever you you put in
the message body as the name of the
custom namespace it just sort of shows
up in Amazon Cloud much it's impossible
to change so if you if you mess up the
name and what a change and you have to
add a new and then wait two weeks for
the other one to to go away but this is
what it looks like and then you can
easily set up alarms this is an example
of a time series of number of rows in a
particular database table over time so
that's it thank you very much and there
was a specific reason in every applied
sorry yeah
you could you you know Pro hostages
because when we were starting with so we
started yeah we we have G lambda
functions one more pop the message you
know kind of so we you will serialize
the metrics before they go into key
pieces and so each like kind of each of
the message bothers is just one data
point
chica instead of kids um so we did not
because that was just way over and
there's no I mean for us we're kind of a
small team and so there's no service or
lending at launch after very easily
you